sh sar from RI jaran I am doing my
engineering from sat engineering College
here sir your lecture after hearing a
lecture our misbelief about Islam and
Muslims vanish
[Applause]
today sir I have been to jamu and
Kashmir and have seen the trauma and
pain that the people are suffering there
because of the so-called Jihad of some
Muslims
sir my question is that does Islam
support such activities if no then what
actually the word Jihad means is it in
accordance with the 56th verse of the
7th chapter of Quran which says do not
Mischief or the 140th verse of 42nd
chapter which says forgiveness is better
than retaliation or the 32nd verse of
the fifth chapter which states if anyone
killed a
person he kills the mankind sir I have
one more question in the same context
and it is that does Islam teach us to
give priority to the religion that is DH
or maab before the country or motherland
that is matumi or Kong thanks a
[Applause]
lot the brother asked very good
questions the first question is
regarding concept of jihad he says that
why are people fighting is been to
Kashmir about Jihad does Islam encourage
this fighting what is the meaning of
jihad does it not disagree with the
quotations he gave of 5:32 brother as
far as the word Jihad is concerned
there's a misconception not only among
the non-muslims but even among the
Muslims what most of the people think
that any War fought by any Muslim for
any reason whether it be for his
personal gain whether it be for politics
whether it be for language whether it be
for color it is called as Jihad Jihad
does not mean any War fought by any
Muslim Jihad comes from the Arabic word
Jad
which means to strive which means to
struggle like how we have so Jihad
basically means to strive to struggle
and in the Islamic context it means to
strive against one's own evil
inclination it also means to strive to
make the society better it even includes
to strive in the battlefield to fight in
self-defense jiad also means to fight
against operation and tyranny Jihad
basically means to strive or struggle
many people have misconception that
Jihad means war and many people
translate Jad is holy war the Arabic
word for holy war
is if you read the Quran nowhere in the
Quran not a single verse nowhere in the
authentic of mhamad Ali wasallam is this
word har M mentioned anywhere there's no
har mad at all the translation of jihad
is not holy war at all this word holy
war was first used by the historians to
describe the Crusades of the Christian
who spread Christianity and who killed
thousands of people in the name of
Christianity Unfortunately today many
people including so-called Muslim
Scholars ined Commerce they translate
Jad the holy war it's a Mis translation
yes Jihad means to strive to struggle
one of the striving can include fighting
fighting also should be in the way of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala that
is now regarding a question that why
does Islam encourage fighting and
killing and there are many critics of
Islam who normally say Islam is a
ruthless religion it always says that we
should kill the non-muslim very find
them many critics including the critic
of India Arun shuri and he writes in his
book The World of fatwa he quotes Sur
chapter number n verse number five and
says that the Quran says wherever you
find a cfir into bracket Hindu that you
kill them and if you open the Quran 9
verse number 5 and if you read it does
say whereever you find a cfir you kill
but this is a quotation out of context
for the context if you read the first
few verses it speaks about a peace
treaty between the mush of Makkah and
the Muslims if you read Surah Toba
chapter 9 first few verses it speaks
about a peace treaty between the Muslim
and mus of Makkah now this peace treaty
was unilaterally broken by the muss of
Makkah by the time Allah subhana wa tala
reaches verse number five he gives them
ultimatum to the mushrik and he tells
them put things straight in four months
time otherwise the declaration of war
and in the battlefield Allah says that
when the enemies come to attack you you
kill the enemies so this verse is is
revealed in the battlefield that when
the enemies come to kill you don't get
scared fight them but natural any army
General today to boost up the morale of
his soldiers he will say that when the
enemies come kill them he'll not say
that just be quiet and Arun shuri after
goinging verse number five he jumps to
verse number seven because verse number
six has the reply Surah 9 verse number
six says that if thef if the enemy seek
ayim if they want peace don't just give
it to them escort them to a place of
security
if the enemy wants peace or
Asylum escort them to place of secure
today the most merciful Army General
maximum will tell his soldiers that let
the enemy go yeah Allah says don't just
let them go escort them to a place of
security so whenever these verses are
there of killing including the vers of
Sur Anar chapter 8 verse number 60 when
they say that prepare your Ste and be
prepared attack the enemy the next ver
say but if the enemy is inclined towards
peace you give it to them so almost all
the verses we talk about fighting after
that it says that if they want peace
peace is better now regarding a question
what about the verses of Sur ma 5:32 Sur
n 4: 40 that if anyone kills any human
being it as though has kill the whole of
humanity this is the basic rule of Islam
that if anyone kills any human being
whether it be a Muslim or non-muslim
unless it be for murder or for creating
Mischief in the land spreading
corruption in the land it is as though
he has killed the whole of humanity and
if anyone saes in human being it is as
though you saved the whole of humanity
now if you read if you read bhagad Gita
bhagad Gita chapter number 2 verse
number 50 it says Krish Shri Krishna
tells Arjun to do Jihad strive if you
read Mahabharat Mahabharat talks about
thousands of verses of fighting
thousands of verses many number of times
more than what the Quran speaks mahabat
is a scripture as you may be aware it
talks about a feud a fight between the
Pand and the K the five the pands and
HED by the kovs fight and bhagwat Gita
is a part of Mahabharat 18 chapters in
which SRI
Krishan Lord he gives advice to Arjun
Arjun says Arjun says in bhagad Gita
chapter number one verse 42 to 46 that I
would
prefer getting killed unarmed rather
than fighting my cousins how can I fight
my cousins the my cousins I would prefer
getting killed unarmed rather than fight
immediately Lord Krishan you know what
does he say in chapter number two verse
number two and three says that how could
such impure thought come in your mind it
is sinful how could you become so
important how could your heart become so
weak so Lord Krishan says such thoughts
are important they are impure they are
sinful it will prevent you from going to
the Heavenly planets going to jna after
that bhagat Gita chapter number two
verse number 3133 says he says Lord
Krishan he says to Arjun that it is the
duty of a shria to fight if he does not
fight he shall not go to heaven and if
you do not fight you are doing a sin so
if you analyze in bhagwat Gita Krishan
says that you have to fight imagine if I
take vers of bhagad Gita and say that
Lord Krishan tells Arjun that you have
to kill your relatives if I quote out of
context it would be devilish but in
context it is Lord Krishan says that if
you have to fight
against falsehood for the truth you can
fight against anyone even if it be your
relatives so now in context it makes
sense that if you have to fight for
justice even if it be against your
relatives there's no problem so that is
the message of bhagwat Gita and
Mahabharat fighting truth against
falsehood the moment I tell a Hindu
about Mahabharat and bhagwat Gita he has
the knowledge he says no but Mahabharat
and bhagwat Gita is a fight between
truth and falsehood that is the same
thing what mentioned in the Quran
so moment I quote to you bhagat Gita
Mahabharat you understand the Quran
better and furthermore many people say
oh this Quran talking about Jihad if you
do Jihad if you die you go to jna many
critics including sh quot and they quote
the even Hadi of bukari volume number
four in the book of jihad chapter number
two Hadith 46 it says that a mujahid is
a person who strives in the way of Allah
subhana wa taala and Allah alone knows
who strive and further a prophet said
that if a mujah dies in the battlefield
he'll J he will get Paradise but if he
returns back if he does not die he will
return back with the booty of War this
Hadith and several vers of the Quran are
quoted by the critics of Islam I wonder
how could the Hindu critics quote these
things having they read the bhagwat Gita
having they read the Mahabharat even
Shri Krishan he mentioned bhagat Gita
chapter number two verse number 37 oh
Arjun oh son of kunti rise up and fight
even if you're killed no problem you
will go to heaven and if you return back
successfully you will get the good
Riches of this Earthly World same thing
as the Hadith so when Krishan says to
Arjun that fight if you are killed no
problem you will go to heaven if you
return back successful you will get the
riches of the world that is the same
thing what s bukari says what the Quran
says so therefore you should understand
each other better by reading the
scripture so Islam allows fighting as
the last resort in self-defense or to
fight against oppression otherwise no
and Jihad means to strive to struggle
now coming to your second question which
is more
important which is more important
following the rules of the country or
following the M the de it's like you
asking me who do I belong to First do I
belong to my father or my mother
first
brother as far as following the rules of
the country and following the rules of
Dean almighty God is concerned almighty
God is our creator he is more Superior
to us following the rules of Dean is
more important for us than any other
rule laid down by father
mother or any country but but I am an
Indian I know there's not a single law
in the Indian constitution which
prevents any Muslim in India to follow
Islam in fact India is one of the few
countries which is mentioned in the
Constitution that it is the right it's
the birth right of every citizen of
India to preach practice his religion
that's what I'm doing
there is not a single law in India which
prevents me from doing something which
is far or compel me for doing something
which is Haram there's no law I can
offer five times of life if I want if I
don't want I can't offer there's not a
single law in the Indian constitution
which prevents me from becoming a good
Muslim therefore as far as I'm concerned
I'm a very practicing Muslim
alhamdulillah and also practicing Indian
and if by
definition by geographical definition an
Indian geographically is called Hindu so
if Hindu means a geographical definition
I a Hindu living in India and I'm a
practicing Muslim